MKBHD just said that the iPhone 14
camera is getting worse is he wrong well
yes at least in some ways now in this
video we're going to show you guys the
ways that it has been getting worse but
not only that how you can fix it right
now and I actually went out and I
updated all of the software on the s22
ultra the pixel 7 Pro and the iPhone it
took some more images to show you guys
the differences but not only that I'll
also show you how some of these issues
that he talked about have actually been
getting better because over the years
I've been comparing the last three
generations of iPhones to see what kind
of improvement we have been getting and
what he did not talk about now right at
the gate I want to say that yes we are
an apple Channel we love our iPhones and
some people say you are biased even in
the unbiased blind camera comparisons
where we don't know which phone took
which photo so because of that I'm
actually bringing in in two professional
photographers to look at over processing
specifically and they can vote which
photo looks the best without knowing the
brand so we have a bunch of photos that
I took if you guys want to see that
video I think it's going to be very
interesting and entertaining make sure
you guys click that subscribe button
down below now I really enjoyed mkbhd's
video he had some awesome Graphics some
great explanations and animations and
one thing he said is that in his test
that he's done the iPhones regularly
lose right away now with that they also
did a more scientific one in the iPhone
place somewhere in the middle but with
that he still gave the iPhone 14 pro the
best overall camera award for the fourth
year in a row so how does that make
sense so why would he do that well this
is what he said that scientific test
that we did tested one specific thing it
tested the the small post and stamp
sized in exposure and colors General
thing with a bunch of different factors
so you can see a small little thumbnail
sized image that's very compressed but
sharpness and detail with all the
compression that we did wasn't tested
also speed of autofocus reliability of
autofocus the open close time of the
camera app how fast and reliable you can
get a shot and also video wasn't tested
so the microphone quality video quality
speed and reliability of autofocus there
file formats sharpness HDR all that
stuff
wasn't tested no I have tested that
against the 13 and the 12 and it took an
insane amount of time I shot over 300
photos and in this 13 and a half minute
video we covered everything so before I
show you guys the differences and where
the iPhone suffers let's see if it
actually has gotten worse over the last
couple of generations in this tough
lighting situation nobody could say that
the 14 pro looks worse than the previous
iPhones because not only is the HDR
better but my face has a lot more detail
and shadowing making for a more natural
looking image and that was one of the
biggest points in his video the faces
are brought up too much they are too
flat and they just look over processed
and in this Sunset image once again the
face looks more natural than the other
shots now it is brought up a little bit
more and we'll see how it compares to
these Android phones with the latest
software updates but saying that the 48
megapixel new sensor having way worse
processing because the software is just
not up to date doesn't look to be the
case we also see that in this image
where the face has more shadowing and
more definition and the 14 pose image
here looks a lot more DSLR like in
natural with 48 megapixels compared to
the 12 megapixel images which Apple has
been using for many many years now one
issue with the iPhone's photos over the
years is that they just had too much
warmth in the face but when we look at
three generations at once the 14 pro Max
looks pretty good we have some
highlights and some shadowing I would
say the 12 Pro Max looks second and the
13 looks the worst so even though I
agreed with them when I initially
watched his video about over processing
and the new sensor when I actually
looked at the side-by-side results from
my own testing I was like no it is not
the case now another sensor that was
updated was the front-facing selfie
sensor it's still 12 megapixels but it's
a brand spanking new one and look at the
results right here it looks more natural
in terms of lighting and they're
focusing on the face instead of the HDR
and with the ultra wide camera which is
still called megapixel the 14 pro Maxes
looks the most natural with the face
being brought up the least and with the
telephoto camera here we see that the
14per Max's 12 megapixel looks the most
natural the least warm and the most
realistic or true to life compared to
the last two generations now there is
one issue with my images is that all of
these are taken with light-skinned
people and just like MKBHD said that is
what the camera is being tuned to
whereas the pixel with Google's real
tone software that focuses on getting
all sorts of skin tones right does a
better job with darker skin tones and I
would have to agree with that but I
can't say that the 14 pro has taken a
step back because of its new sensor now
outside of people one thing I can't say
for sure is that Apple has turned turned
up the contrast in the saturation with
this 14 pro when you don't have a person
in your photo you guys can clearly see
that the saturation contrast is boosted
up the skies are boosted up a lot closer
to what the pixel has done and in the
past apples really had their contrast
turned down but now they are kicking
that up now I would say that I prefer
the 14 pro Max's shot here the grass
looks green the sky looks blue but in
reality it was not that saturated in
terms of color as to what my eye saw now
this extra contrast and saturation has
caused problems for me we have been
recently shopping for countertops for
our kitchen remodel that we are doing
and I noticed that when I would take a
picture it wouldn't look like the real
life slabs that I was taking a photo of
and other people have mentioned this
where some people are now shooting video
and then pulling screen grabs from that
video to get accurate colors which is a
exactly what I was doing here's one
example that I got from our updated
blind camera comparison that we're doing
and you can see the regular photo has
much more contrast and saturation than
the 4K video clip which looks way closer
and more true to life than the photos
Apple's processing is different between
both of those and I know that my real
estate photographer friend which will be
coming on for that blend comparison you
stick photos with his iPhone so that he
can edit the raw photo more true to life
based on the scene which you can no
longer do and I think that is a bigger
issue now some people say that you
should use a real camera because it
doesn't have all that extra processing
like MKBHD showed off where you have the
HDR you have noise reduction you have
brightening of the subject but there is
one big caveat that a lot of people
don't know about or they don't mention
when you take a raw photo it is just raw
data so because of that when you open it
up well you need to edit it yourself so
you're the one that's doing the
processing now if you open up that photo
you will get a different result based on
what program you open it with so you
can't really say that it's true to life
so here in a Mac OS program you have one
set Affinity another and Lightroom the
photo looks totally different and then
when you go to edit it's up to you to
choose your exposure your brightness
your saturation you choose what you want
the image to look like and then with
that you also have a bunch of filters
and AI options the Lightroom has which
can brighten the face but it looks
hilariously bad compared to what the
iPhone is doing and the end result is
all up to you right here we have one
edited one just opened up in either
these images look like they did in real
life now I have one tip for you guys
that do have an iPhone 14 pro or Pro max
if you want to get those natural colors
back and that is to shoot with prora
instead even if you don't edit it and
you just use the tip that I showed off
where you can convert the prora to heic
to make a much smaller photo but still
regain all the detail and the more
natural processing let me show you guys
the difference here so we have a regular
photo on the left and a prora unedited
and converted on the right and you guys
could see that the regular shot
brightens up his face a lot more the
Shadows are lighter not like it is right
now recording me and then the pro route
looks a lot better and more natural and
not only that you guys can see how much
more detail you get in its real detail
not over sharpened because it's 48
megapixels not 12 and then we have a
massive difference in terms of
compression issues where we have a lot
of artifacts with the regular shots but
the converted Pro raw looks so much
cleaner and better and you might think
that the file size will be just
absolutely be massive but look at the
difference 2.1 megabytes compared to
3.9 yes it's bigger but it's not a huge
difference once you make the conversion
and delete the pro raw image so I would
absolutely say if you're having the
issue the MKBHD talked about the face
being too bright or too saturated use
this with your iPhone to get much better
looking photos now with that said how's
the pixel 7 Pro and s22 Ultra compare
with their latest software updates that
I made sure to do and here we have that
same image and you see that the pixel 7
Pro actually brought up redeem space
more so now of course yes he is light
skinned so that might be a difference
but the iPhone does have more shadowing
on the face now in this shot with a lot
of white the iPhone's face is brought up
more so than the pixels but you guys let
me know which one you prefer and in this
tough selfie shot with harsh lighting
that I did on purpose to look at the
shadowing the iPhone is somewhere in the
middle and of course mkbsg didn't talk
about the selfie camera in his video now
here is a shot of a house and here you
can see that the iPhone is way too warm
without a subject there and the house is
white in reality and in this one the
face is brought up more so than the
pixel but not as much as the Samsung
here's another really tough shot that is
backlit with lighting coming in outside
that window and you guys let me know
does the iPhone look like its face is
brought up way too much or does it look
fairly natural and of course with that
if we crop in we look at the other parts
of the images in terms of detail
artifacts and noise and you guys let me
know which one you like better now there
are a few more images that I found with
the iPhone but not ones that have to do
with the new 48 megapixel sensor for
example for selfie shots that don't have
light in your face I consistently saw
that the iPhone was too flat and too
cool in the winter time now in these the
pixel looks too dark for my liking but
the Samsung looks amazing in every
single way I took a ton of different
photos that we are going to be covering
in that blind camera comparison along
with video for example we have the slabs
here and I wanted to see which one looks
most true to life and in this case it is
the iPhone and that's why I was grabbing
screenshots from video but make sure you
guys are subscribed so you guys see that
blind camera comparison with
professional photographers choosing
which one looks the best and which one
is the most over processed to see is it
really the iPhone I can't wait to hear
their opinions so make sure you guys
have notifications enabled as well now
the iPhone does have some other issues
with this new sensor I would say the
main one is the fact that the mineral
focusing distance is really terrible
like we've shown off in the past
compared to the 12 and the 13 It's much
further now it does have that macro mode
uh you guys see in this bug shot when
Apple enabled it last year tried to fix
that but the image looks way worse than
before so because of that a lot of times
I'll just enable the 2x mode get further
away and take a better looking photo and
that just has to do with the lens that's
in here the sensor is larger and even
though this camera bump is the biggest
that we have had ever it's still not big
enough for this sensor and photographers
will spend a lot of money for example we
upgraded two lenses just because the
middle focusing distance was much better
so that is what I would like to see with
the iPhone 15s so with that said the
iPhone does have some issues including
some color and contrast issues that it
don't like for me personally you can
edit your photos and you have your own
preferences but I will not say that the
new sensor is what is really hurting
Apple because comparing it to the
previous generation even with the issues
that were mentioned things have gotten
better but you guys let me know your
thoughts down below don't miss out the
blind camera compare is going to be
amazing if you guys want to pick up one
of these iPhones or these Androids use a
YouTube shopping feature the card and
link below click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those great
videos right there like the ultimate
comparison with the generations it's
been Max and I'll see you in the next
one
[Music]